that um was my first time back on stage
in 410 days exactly and it feels good
so let's get five suggestions i'll start
with
you guys over there because you were
kind of like prepping it so what was
what was your suggestion over here
just jesus thank you very much what was
lovely was there's like four of you
there and there was all this cross talk
about stuff and then you just like
no ignore all these fools just jesus
chris and how he is our personal lord
and savior and that's good right jesus
just not jesus just jesus um cool let's
get another suggestion from people
over here what'd you reckon
rococo french art thank you very much
everyone else
is not impressed but you feel very
clever yeah you just fist bumped someone
that's the
it's only on a monday night at the
comedy cellar that you're going to go
rococo french art
yeah my degree will be useful so
rococo french art just jesus and now my
german friends i want to get a
suggestion from you guys
um you can make it german you can make
it not it can be whatever you want
i just would love to hear it
okay i know a lot of you didn't hear
that but it was the most
german answer ever the opportunity cost
of time
[Laughter]
and you threw it off so casually it was
i don't know i thought
it was the opportunity cost of time it
was very good
lovely rococo french art the opportunity
cost of time
just jesus we're really we're going so
cool this is so wide now um
there's there's two suggestions left
i'll come to
if you're in this kind of wedge here
what do you want to wrap that
experience so someone said something at
the back let me get that first
dinosaurs that's a very common
suggestion i don't like 10 suggestions
twice
so i apologize what did you say
shakespearean shakespearean
soliloquies do you have a favorite one i
actually don't
you actually don't no but no it was
that's fine too many
there's too many to pick from that's
cool okay cool so shakespearean
soliloquies
tell you what else you don't have a
specifically favorite one let's throw
dinosaurs in there so uh a shakespearean
soliloquy
dinosaurs we'll figure out what that's
going to be um people over here
any of you what would you like to hear a
rapper disco attacking a museum
a museum discotheque that sounds like a
very cool new york event has that
happened
not yet oh no i think we just invented
an app over there that's awful
great so to remind you all the
suggestions are just
jesus rococo french uh yeah woo jesus
he's great
the opportunity cost of time uh
shakespearean soliloquy about dinosaurs
and a discotheque in a museum let me wet
my whistle
does that mean something different over
here yes did you does
uh that probably means something about
penises doesn't it oh
that's disgusting i apologize someone
over there just just went no it doesn't
no well
you and i can believe that uh this
lovely people of the comedy seller is a
freestyle rap as i said a wrap made up
on the spot based intelligent
suggestions not written on play not
rehearsed
um please don't worry it won't be
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly totally bad as you're
expecting a privately educated middle
class white british boy to be
you guys seem really unconvinced over
there if we can drop the beat good sir
let's uh have some fun and you can crank
that yeah
i'm feeling the pulse i'm feeling the
pulse and i love the woo from down here
that's great
[Music]
[Applause]
little woo like a freaky ghost and then
we off we go
to the bordeaux coast when i'm over
there you best know
i'm checking out the art the roll cold
cold that's three little holes like a
long orgasm when it comes to studying
art there's a vast chasm
of understanding presumably between you
and me i just sit there like louise 16th
that's the sun king
admiring all other fun things you'll be
on your phone maybe just coming like nah
this ain't within my plan i like the
more modern stuff like paul gogan that's
a
french artist not the impressionist if
you don't like
cold cold then i'm getting pissed it's
got the gold ornate floral scrolls
it was painted like 400 years ago maybe
more recently hard to do the mental mass
if i'm feeling injured
if i'm feeling attacked from all sides
then you know that i be going i'm up on
a cross
jesus with the romans around my feet
yeah i know it won't please just if you
are religious
saying just jesus no holy trinity it's
kind of odd what just jesus no holy
spirit or god nah
just a guy who's a hebrew talk about all
of the miracles that he do
he's on the big crucifix with the nails
through his wrist saying
jesus are you glad that you picked this
path to travel down
what you're saying now you want to
travel up elevate upon a cloud
he says no chris obviously there's no
god above
why because it's just me jesus solo with
the holes that's the little
thing it's a religious riddle and a
pickle when i go over there
to the met to the gala maybe national
history i push it much farther than
anyone did
i say let me see him take your mdma
in a museum put a disco ball don't mess
up the [ __ ] and do coke in there while
the ball spins in the glitter
people go crazy they're like in the day
it's educational
bird night it's a rave it's so gosh darn
fun
without fail you can shimmy with a lady
when you're underneath the whale that's
the big
blue one it's hanging from the ceiling
shakespeare
ever so revealing hamlet stands in a
bold position and starts
to soliloquize on the human condition
like a last poetic horatio
such a fine example of a fellow you know
and the other gravedigger he says
sup ham that's not actually the skull of
a man and hamlet a 16 year old prince
what you get he's pathetic he says oh
[ __ ]
this a t-rex it's really far too rigged
for my hands
probably a little raptor would be less
ground but that's okay
an actor talking about the dinosaurs
have you ever seen it
like laura done before there in jurassic
park she can do a monologue now the last
thing germans know how to do the job
purposefully
it's always on their minds they're like
yes you have to be about time
every minute that slips that's with
impunity it's horrible i like to think
about the opportunity cost
otherwise my boss fires me he says yo
manfred please agree sit down there
i know you are tired but if you don't
work harder you're going to get fired he
says
every minute wasted is a dollar i don't
earn technically a euro
then will i learn all the numbers i know
yeah we can check it i don't give a [ __ ]
about the euro cause we got brexit
you